the story begins on a normal afternoon
when a girl walking down a path notices
a pretzel stall nearby the seller gladly
hands her a pretzel but asks for three
kisses in return the girl seems shocked
at first but she happily kisses him on
the lips and walks away it is then
revealed that kisses have replaced paper
money and have become the world currency
a realtor is showing a couple around a
house they are looking to buy after
everything is finalized they are asked
to pay two hundred thousand dollars up
front the husband simply steps back as
the wife and the realtor start kissing
they go on and on for about an hour but
only reach up to one thousand somewhere
else a street singer is kissed by random
passerby as a tip similarly a group of
friends at a restaurant split the bill
taking turns to kiss the waitress a boss
is distributing paychecks to his
employees at the end of the month but
because checks and banks don't work in
this world he has to kiss a hundred
people in a day a more interesting scene
can be seen outside in an alleyway where
a dealer is exchanging drugs for kisses
they even get into an argument when the
customer tries to cut the last kiss
short back to the realtor and the woman
who have lost count of the kisses but
are still going on the waitress finally
gets done being showered with kisses and
is given a smooch as a tip back to the
pretzel girl who liked the last one so
much that she returns to get another but
this time their kiss is stolen by a
thief who runs away with it thankfully a
cop gets the man before he escapes and
makes out with him to get the stolen
kisses back and that's the end of that
one the second story is about a man
named hatsuno who wakes up with an x on
his forehead initially he thinks it is a
prank and tries to remove it with water
but the mark doesn't go away he asks his
wife to remove it but to his surprise
she doesn't see the mark he hides his
forehead with a handkerchief and makes
his way to work at one point his
assistant inquires if he has a headache
and is told about the mark but like
hatsuno's wife she doesn't see anything
this makes him register that only he can
see the mark which means he doesn't need
to worry about people judging him still
he remains worried about the sudden
abnormal appearance hatsuna's wife
notices he is stressed about something
and asks him to visit the doctor hatsuno
takes the advice but even the doctor
doesn't see anything wrong with him he
assumes the man is stressed and
prescribes a bunch of medicine on his
way back hatsuno is still worried but
then he comes across another guy with an
identical mark on his forehead they jump
in excitement having finally discovered
that they are not alone a while later
they are at a roadside restaurant
talking about their experiences with the
mark the man's name is kira and he got
the mark two months ago he knows a bit
more about it because his father also
had the mark appear on his forehead
right before his death kira thinks that
the mark means they are about to die in
a few days but hatsuno doesn't believe
him they exchange numbers and decide to
keep in touch in case they find out more
about the marks one day hatsuno is
watching tv when he sees the news about
a dead person in his last speech he has
an x mark on his forehead that only
hatsuno can see shocked he gives kira a
call only to find out that he died a few
days ago in the next scene hatsuno goes
to his funeral and sees that the mark
has disappeared it is clear that kira's
prediction was true which means hatsuno
is about to die as well he knows that he
cannot prevent it so he decides to live
the little time he has to the fullest
that day at work he meets a client
desperately in need of alone hatsuno
grants him the push and is happy to have
made an impact on his life the deed
provides him a bit of satisfaction
making him feel his death is not so bad
after all it is also his wife's birthday
so on his way back home he gets her a
present but on the train he notices
everyone around him has a mark on their
foreheads realizing that it is about to
crash he gets off at the next station
but the horror follows him when he sees
that everyone at the station has the
mark as well hatsuno runs outside but
the mark follows him everywhere even to
his home the news on tv reveals that a
virus with a hundred percent mortality
rate is spreading all around asia in the
last scene the japanese politician tells
the people to rest assured declaring the
virus is not dangerous at all however
hatsuno who knows the truth screams in
frustration
the third story sets around a world
where the concept of lying hasn't been
discovered people always tell the truth
no matter what it results in the episode
begins at a wedding where a pretty woman
is marrying a conventionally
unattractive man their best friend
delivers a speech for the newlyweds and
reveals that the woman is only marrying
the man for money moreover she has
already been in a relationship with
their other friends shotaro who is also
at the wedding an enraged groom attacks
shotaro causing a big mess these kinds
of conflicts are common in a world with
no lies all advertisements thieves and
even politicians always tell the truth a
day after the wedding shotaro is laid
off from his work he argues with his
boss that their product sucks but it
doesn't get him the job back after the
eventful day he goes out with his
girlfriend but she too breaks up with
him it turns out that her senior at work
is approaching her and she wants to give
him a chance because of his status tired
of his bad luck shotaro makes his way
back home suddenly he sees a purse on
the ground and picks it up but is caught
by a policeman while doing so he tries
explaining that he was about to hand
over the purse to its owner but the
policeman doesn't listen he assumes
shotaro is a burglar and points a gun at
him shotaro's life flashes in front of
his eyes and in a moment of panic he
says the purse belongs to him the cop
doesn't ask him further questions and
leaves shotaro doesn't realize what he
just did and returns home in exhaustion
he lives with his father who has found
out that his son is unemployed
embarrassed about his life shotaro
claims that he got a corporate job just
today his father believes him which
leaves him in shock in the next scene he
meets friends and tells them about the
new discovery initially they don't
understand the concept of lying but
shotaro teaches them using examples by
the end of an hour they start lying for
fun just because they can they go to
restaurants and eat for free claiming
that they have already paid similarly
after having fun for a few more days
shotaro suggests they use their talent
to make money he picks up two water
bottles and declares that the water
gives people happiness the friends start
a company of happy water and people buy
into the attractive slogan thinking that
the water will make them happy in only a
month the trio turns into millionaires
shotaro buys a mansion for his father
but on the day of the move he gets a
call from his friends their headquarters
are raided by their customers
complaining that their water didn't
bring them happiness to get out of
trouble shotaro claims that the effects
of the water are seen in three to five
years the crowd disperses but a little
girl named yuki doesn't move her mother
suffered from a terminal disease and
died and she blames shotaro for it
because his water gave them hope he
feels awful for the little girl but she
runs away before he gets to her
following that the friends sit down and
decide to stop producing the fake water
then we see shotaro visit yuki's home
where her grandmother reveals how much
hurt the little girl has been through
because of the fake water shotaro finds
yuki and lies to her for the last time
he tells her that her mother called him
before her death and said she loved her
daughter to the moon and back even when
she dies she will watch over her from
afar yuki feels her heart calmed down
and thanks him for informing her of the
message then shotaro turns himself in
telling the police about the discovery
the world changes because of him and
advertisements are no longer true the
politicians and thieves get away with
anything but fights and conflicts also
decrease drastically in the last scene
shotaro gets out of prison and reunites
with his friends hoping to start a new
life the last story revolves around a
japanese man named ryota who has never
had a girlfriend or any admirable
success in his life one morning he wakes
up to a box at his front door he doesn't
remember ordering anything which makes
him curious about the contents of the
box he opens it carefully but is
underwhelmed by a pair of glasses inside
the scene cuts to a day earlier ryota
was going through a mental spiral
because of his non-existent love life
and his lousy job last night he drank
several cans of alcohol before matching
with a beautiful girl named misa on a
dating site today is the day they are
supposed to meet and ryota decides to
elevate his style with the glasses but
upon wearing them he instantly realizes
they are not a usual pair the box
assures any customer who wears them will
be shown a path to happiness i already
fell for this [ __ ] last week with the
water says ryota they turn out to be
smart glasses that scan people in
situations for ryota and tell him
exactly what he should say or do ryota
is skeptical but he decides to give it a
try nonetheless at first he takes some
time to get accustomed to them but he
soon finds them useful the glasses count
calories and stamina and tell him what
he should eat they also tell him what
path is the shortest route to his
destination and at what speed he should
walk but they come in the most handy
when he finally meets his date misa as
the couple greets each other the glasses
scan mises social media and find out
about her interest in art and museums at
the glass's advice ryota suggests they
go to a museum for a date misa is happy
to have found a man with the same
interest as her she excitedly asks him
what he thinks about the art she likes
ryota freezes because he doesn't even
understand the terminology and quickly
asks the glasses for help then he is
shown a book and asked to read a few
lines from it by the end of the trip
misa is thoroughly impressed with the
knowledge ryota possesses they go to a
restaurant for dinner where ryota
follows proper dining manners thanks to
his new mentor then suddenly a man falls
unconscious and stops breathing because
of a respiratory problem everyone panics
but no one knows how to assist him this
is when ryota comes to help and performs
cpr with the help of the glasses a few
minutes later the man is saved and misa
is moved by ryota's kindness and courage
on their way back home she asks him out
on a second date starting that day ryota
never takes the glasses off for a second
of his life he becomes completely
dependent on them from buying clothes to
choosing what he wants to eat that day
he also does significantly better at
work as the glasses tell him just the
thing he must say to impress the boss
ultimately ryota is promoted to the
manager of his branch after only a month
of owning the glasses ryota's life has
turned upside down one afternoon he
brings misa to his house looking to
propose to her the glasses even provide
him with the script that will impress
her enough for her to say yes but just
when he starts reading it the glasses
run out of power and he has to make up
an excuse to put them on charge he goes
out to buy a cake for both of them but
in his absence misa finds out about the
device and reads the entire proposal
script ryota returns a while later and
tries to continue the date but misa
stops him from embarrassing himself
further disclosing that she knows about
the glasses ryota explains that he is
just bad at relationships which is why
he took the help but misa doesn't want
to listen to any explanations she feels
awful for falling for his charade and
claims that she wants to be in love with
him not the glasses ryota takes them off
promising to be himself from now onwards
probably a bad idea ryota the following
day misa is at work when ryota
approaches her to apologize again he
doesn't have the glasses on and is kept
to the promise that he made yesterday he
tells misa how much he loves her and
proposes to her with a ring when misa
agrees to marry him we find out he is
wearing a lens replacement for the
glasses a flashback from last night
reveals that his promise and him
throwing his precious belongings away
was also a suggestion from the device
unaware of all of this misa is happy to
be engaged to the love of her life
somewhere else the couple is being
broadcasted live in a meeting the
manufacturers of the glasses used ryota
as a test subject to prove its
efficiency the episode ends when they
make a deal with an investor to make the
glasses commercial subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching